now what's wrong
because I know I'm I'm getting defensive
who is that
you're playing in the picture who is
that
about what's wrong ah you know what's
wrong
Kevin
[Music]
though you literally what you did as
well yeah yeah yeah I did I looked at
you to see if you're still looking at me
are you uh
[Music]
anyway guys we're back I'm starting
today I'm starting to diggers always
wants to run his mouth with this stupid
question starting the show I'm saying
stuff today what do you saying I'm
important and I'm here I'm going
straight into questions of the week I've
heard great things about this question
of the week guys so let's get started
without any further Ado Fire Lord Flags
what is the question of the week what's
something you should have told your
other half before you got together
I have had good things something you
should have told your other half before
you got together for you wow tell me
you've got Juicy Juice I have Juicy
Juice all right say less I have Juicy
Juice yeah Mom
um I slept with many men sometimes five
at a time sometimes old ones too
sometimes five at a time that's a train
track but he's not laugh the idea of
just getting absolutely yeah dashed yeah
like a bed sheet yeah yeah yeah
wow sometimes old ones that's just
you're scratching itches
you just don't you don't want
relationships you should have told him
this
I remember actually
the girl that I said we clapped and then
never spoke again yes
she was on staff in uni oh like crud or
no I'm saying I'm saying the one no no
no no no no no no you'll think of
someone else I'm thinking of bird shirt
oh yeah yeah I was thinking of someone
else
[Music]
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yeah yeah that slip and slide yeah yeah
I'm talking about birds yeah okay yeah
yeah
obviously she like I sold like later on
she got like married and YouTube yeah
everything yes yes yes I remember
thinking surely he doesn't know he can't
yeah no surely he doesn't know the stuff
oh no because I think
I think maybe you sent me her I just
someone sent me an idea I saw it and she
was engaged or married or and she was
pregnant yeah maybe you said maybe
someone else sent it to me but this
obviously was years ago I was thinking
there's no way my man knows what she's
been through oh bro he looks so innocent
he looked innocent and I didn't believe
he was white I couldn't they were just
on a beach or something yeah yeah I
couldn't believe the same I believe
brother was white I was like wow she
really settled down she changed up yeah
yeah settled down that is the worst
Escape that street life yeah but he
can't find out he can't find out yeah
because like if you actually deep it
like if you sat homeboy down and was
like brother in uni your girl was a
freak she was a thought before the word
thought existed that's what she was
and she was
exclusively melanin that's all she
wanted a different Mel different night
yeah facts bro for years yeah I don't I
don't know how
I don't know how she patterned that and
I don't know how you pattern that as
well because
there's you you'd somehow find some
you'd find something you know that kids
engaged like obviously they've been
together for a while clearly so you must
have found something in the past yeah
bro she really left that life behind us
that's a pastor leave behind I would
love to sit her down and be like did you
really leave it yeah did you really live
about it yeah
or do you just like bury a deep inside
yeah because that's just that's not
there you really are that's what the UI
know yeah yeah that's not the you I know
wow you were really really about it and
I was about it yeah you were scary
yeah you made me think different bro
Jesus
anyway crazy
um what's something you should have told
your other half before you got together
that all my other partners have
restraining orders against me
scary stuff that's impossible all of my
other partners I say this I'm so tired
of saying this sentence on this show
because we say it all the time but I
promise you that's something I couldn't
hear yeah
a restraining order the love of my life
should have told you this
All My Exes have restraining orders
against me
us
there's nothing you can say yeah
because they all didn't make a mistake
yeah facts all you are the common
denominator so what have you been doing
I'll be thinking how do I get out of my
house how do I get out of my house today
I'd get one just because
if my girl told me yeah yeah my exes
have restraining orders I'm applying for
one on the spot yeah you're safe
facts bro yeah that's um yeah that's
scary time scary hours wow um
I hate her kid
[Laughter]
shut up I don't want this one this
little thing running around here I don't
know what him or her I want you yeah
facts I want this kid I want you yes I'm
just dealing with you yeah I don't want
this kid baby
I used to think that as a kid all the
time with my stepdad yeah
my mom
you don't want me and I don't want you
your facts come out facts bro facts yeah
wow yeah yeah yeah that I like to bite
when I'm horny
[Laughter]
wow
yeah
yeah but I've got my tensile Chef is
different I need bruises yeah because
I'm a sucking bike
yeah yeah I don't wanna like open my
mouth
if you're getting past canines yeah yeah
you're saying else you're hungry you're
not horny you're hungry yeah
course
that I have false teeth it fell out
whilst I was giving him a BJ
yeah that's not a lie we can move on
from yeah false teeth plural yeah she's
just got the whole set just yanked off
yeah yeah because I'm livid because I've
lips to you facts I've lips to you and
whatever everything
porcelain is in there I'm fat my
tongue's been up in there I'm [__] I
feel bit betrayed
I feel betrayed because look at you
about it
gummy bear you're just a gummy bear
without it
wow and I also need to know the roots
are you on meth
why are you teethless are you a meth
addict what's going on why are you
toothless yeah how to train your dragon
why are you toothless
wow oh my days
I used to be a Man Too
see stuff like this two
stuff like this
this is mad like when I oh no no that's
not because
that's Jerry Springer yeah
that's Ricky Lakewood
Used To Be A Man Too
wow and the thing is though the word
that we're living in someone in the
comments are gonna be like why should
she have to tell him
someone in the comments gonna say why
should she have to say that it's safer
don't dead name her you know this is a
safe space she is who she is yeah she
doesn't owe him anything
the tube is spun two
also yeah I don't I don't know where
medicine is at the minute but you can't
lie to me like that but I'm I will suss
it yep I'm starting on day one yeah I
will assassin because I'm very um what's
the word I'm looking for
um attentive when it comes yeah same
yeah okay
[Laughter]
ask right ask it with common sense if
I'm asking it with pure Common Sense
okay innocence yeah and righteous intent
okay
if we're in a situation let's say we not
mean you yeah but you're in a situation
with a dang yeah with an absolute thing
yeah
and you're drunk
you're not being as attentive as you
would on a normal day okay
she hops straight for the loop and
you're about oh so we're in a close
space
down okay you're getting down down okay
okay okay
um she hopped straight for the loop and
you're like gang you're not even
thinking straight
and your
I don't know
five Strokes deep
and then on the fifth stroke you're like
hmm like you're acknowledging it doesn't
feel like a normal yeah it does feels
tight it doesn't feel like the tone that
you're used to yeah
and it almost feels like you might have
to re-lube
um it's just skin on skin yeah yeah yeah
yeah
another stroke yeah another stroke yeah
and you see a tiny little scar here just
under where an Adam's apple might have
been yeah
I'm not saying it was yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and in that moment
in time yeah
and then you look
and okay now we're in Stroke Nine okay
and it's still getting good to you yeah
you're a human being yeah and this is a
thing yeah okay okay it's still getting
good to you yeah you look up and see a
picture on the mantelpiece yeah
of
someone who looks very much like her
but also not yeah it could be her From
Another Dimension yeah
or a twin
a previous life yeah we're 13 Strokes
deep now yeah yeah and you're going for
it yeah she's saying stuff yeah she says
crazy stuff and she's yeah she's done
okay
we're now moving on to stroke like 18
yeah
and you've one million established what
we're doing okay I'm here I have clocks
everything you've clocked everything
okay
are you finishing up
um
I don't think that's down to me in the
sense that my tool does weigh once you
see what I'm saying REM I don't think
it's down to me let's say in once you've
like that's so ravened it yes
yeah what's the reality is dived into
your pupil yeah and if that's so ravened
it yeah let's say you lose
percent of wood okay but you can still I
can still buy it I can still do I need
to do but you know if you lock in yeah
you just have to listen to the stuff
that she's saying don't block it out
yeah listen to this kind of films
are you powering through are you are you
gonna stop this whole party right here
um
is it still wet considering I've lived
up twice now you haven't moved up twice
you can just it's just getting at like
you can you'll you'll finish your job
yeah on this one application okay but
the friction is getting less or it's
getting worse yeah yeah yeah yeah
um it's not getting slippier like you
used to yeah um
laughs
[Music]
um
would I finish
I'm probably broke
I mean probably bro
right
before we take a step further pull out a
change open your mouth oh sweat probably
bro a step further
if the Tums are getting dry yeah if the
cheese is getting dry I need something
wet yeah I open up in it
first of all I know I can
that's I'm thinking of like pros and
cons yeah yeah as we're going through it
I'm trying to I'm trying to imagine as
many Pros as possible okay I don't
finish the straight in there okay
um so that's I know this is for a fact
um
I don't know my brain really does run
away with me sometimes so like yeah
when I lose that 30 I could Panic facts
bro I could panic and uh lose it all so
so I Lose I'm not getting up again yeah
oh If I Lose I'm not getting up again no
way so I'm hoping I can I'm saying okay
these are the if I can lock in I'm
locking in and then but we might have to
take this to another level okay okay we
might have to take this to another level
okay like what
I don't know a quiet joke I don't no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no I don't know what the level's gonna
be okay but I'm just I'm saying whatever
she's saying
[Applause]
I'm gonna have to tell her get get
twisted yeah yeah let's get twisted
because
you know I don't want to be in this
reality yeah you know I know so let me
finish you know I know so lock in and
yeah let me help you yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah because you're not mad
yeah fam you're not nothing so actually
maybe we're about to flip up and do some
prostate stuff not for me
not for me yeah but yeah yeah yeah yeah
real will Schmick yeah yeah I might have
to get shame or
um so I can yeah I can lock it in and
finish this party because otherwise icon
no I'm deep in it now I don't think I
would finish okay because I'm promising
you I'm losing that 30 and I will get
scared and then I'm running through the
embarrassment of her asking me what's
wrong yeah
and as soon as that gets in my head bang
Bang Yeah I've got no blood down here
I'm everything here yeah what's wrong
fam midqui no no no you can't ask them
questions bam you can't ask them
questions to a man what's wrong no
what's wrong
because I know I'm I'm getting defensive
who is that
you're playing in the picture who is
that
about what's wrong ah you know what's
wrong
Kevin yeah
you know what's wrong bro
you're not helping me oh [__] and I'm
here I'm here but if we're gonna start
asking questions
yeah I don't know I don't know that's
wild anyway back to it yeah um what's
something you should have told your
other half before you got together
that I can't afford the lifestyle I've
been giving her for months I've been
there oh I've been there I remember
really yeah I remember when I first
started dating I said you started day we
went on a few dates um there was a chick
you know who it is but it's a while ago
um and
I think this was back when I was still
bartending as well oh dear and yeah she
was older than me and it was just one of
those ones where I wasn't privy to the
lifestyle that these men were on were on
okay I was driving that 306 back then as
well I was scraping I was getting paid
every every other week but my gums
weren't showing I was getting paid every
week you know what I mean my Petty tank
wasn't showing us
because I was active with her yeah I'm
thinking I can't do that I work five
days a week doubles yeah and you want me
to date you on a Saturday every Saturday
I'm tired yeah I couldn't live up to
this standard oh yeah so it was like it
was long it was long yeah I've never had
that but
thank God because I'm so prideful for
you yeah yeah yeah I'm so prideful
there's there's not a thing that could
turn to Me In Black I just don't think
you can afford my lifestyle and for me
to be like facts I can't yeah I'm just
not man enough yeah I'm not mature
enough to do it I swear I couldn't
afford everything you need
and more I can afford everything yeah
and more yeah what do you need tell me
and I'll cry at home
arguing
why should Birkin why should I what
facts I can't yeah but why should I
impress me yeah fat impress me then
maybe I'll get you from juggle or
something yeah yeah yeah so I ain't seen
before
all right
in fact it's seen before that I sleep
talk apparently saying he's here is
scary when staying over for the first
time
imagine he's here imagine hearing that
oh [__] I promise you I'm shaking you
I'm grabbing your jaw and the top of
your head and I'm shaking you who he's
here
and I look you in your eyes are just
roll back like that he's here
nah and I'm slapping you yes the facts
he's here I like having sex outside
um
you don't need to tell me that before
let me find out spontaneously don't need
to tell me that let me find out
spontaneously yeah
he should have told me he had the child
on the way oh dear I'm exactly like the
other guys
jokes I'm exactly like the other guys
everyone
that's so funny she's my other quarter
not my half
wow just yeah DVD up he divvied it up
she's my other quarter wow his twin his
twin brother tries to get with me not
tried tries continuously to get with me
twin brother
fam thing is what I grew up thinking I
would love to have a twin I think it'd
be the coolest [__] of all time but that
that will send it's another level of
betrayal that I can't send prize yeah no
that's an evil twin Rider boy [__]
um
that was again evaluated for bipolar
disorder
Peak that we don't that we won't speak
during Ramadan oh I swear
oh God
couldn't maintain a relationship if I
was Muslim
Ramadan yeah starving starving yeah I'm
not chatting to anyone bro that month
don't chat to me I would be moody well I
used to I used to do it anyway yeah yeah
would you bear Moody all the time hell
bro yeah and I'd fake it as well not
fake the moods obviously fake like fake
fasting and fast from like I remember
when I was in yeah seven
um obviously you're eating like morning
Before Sunrise
um I'd fast till lunch eat my lunch come
home
um act as if like I'll be I'm busy I'm
in bed yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
basically I've had all the liquid on the
bus
and then yeah obviously I'm starving at
eight o'clock when I get in starving
eight o'clock yeah I've had all the
liquids on the bus all the liquids
fairness intense there's no way yeah
because these men are wondering why
you're not finishing your dinner yeah
but Ian's day break why are you not
eating your dinner
like obviously don't get me wrong props
to everyone that fast and that is is
incredible it's amazing I just I know
what I'm like my stomach controls me
your summer just control you bro I can't
imagine a day of you fasting one day I'd
lose my mind I bet you would
we should do it as an experiment one
time I would leave the yard I promise
you really I promise I won't leave the
order all right next next in Ramadan
thing is I know I can do a day just one
day yeah next Ramada maybe we should try
is like a little social experiment it's
gonna be around the same month as well
or at the same time period so yeah yeah
we'll just pick like a day or two okay
we'll see yeah we'll see
we'll see anyway I've got a few more
what's something
what's something you should have told
your other half before you got together
Saturdays and Sundays are for football
and I like to watch that [__] alone oh
so that's you in it not necessarily I'm
like watching [__] alone I can't watch
football with anyone you know you don't
need to be here
you're watching it I'm focused yeah I'm
focused but if you want to be here you
know what I mean but I'm easy either way
yeah I'm easy either way I'm watching it
regardless yeah yeah perfect
I was only flirting with her because one
of my enemies was in love with her
Jesus that's not something I thought I'd
hear a man say fox bro that's gal stuff
that is girl stuff that's gout stuff one
of my enemies long that's that's just
long I got time for that
I got an abortion because it may not
have been his kid
before you met them you know before they
got together oh wow
they have two years before I leave
country and go to law school
you always knew this you've got two
years big man
two years have fun have fun if you want
to love me love me if you don't love me
don't that's your business you've got
two years
I'm gone after that right and then you
know what's dread because two years is a
long time as well there's not even so
short that you're like I'm not even a
bother yeah two years yeah that's a
whole lesson that's that's long that's
longer than 90 of my relationships
that's an investment bro two years would
be a magical you because you know she's
leaving it with the most magical two
years of your life
I mean would it as a social experiment
if you want to be with this person they
said fall in love what if you fall in
love you're going to fall in love this
is what I'm trying to make so why would
it be magical because it's like
it's dread it's like it's like our
friendship I told you like I've got like
cancer we're gonna be boys for the next
two years
yeah okay we're gonna make it work bro
you're not gonna waste time arguing with
me yeah yeah yeah if you know you're
with this person for two years you're
not gonna waste like
a week of not chatting after an argument
I guess you're gonna make it work bro I
guess you're gonna fall in love She's
got a hold of you she's gonna
she's got a hold of you she has to hold
her you she has to hold you because I
need to run it back but the thing is as
soon as she changes her mind says I'm
not going to law school yeah
come on my yard you liar
you're just a liar that's exactly what
you are yeah the fantasy's done oh
you're just
you're just a liar all right I've got
two more
I Sleepwalk jump off balconies smash a
TV holes in the wall kind of sleep walk
I can that's not sleepable I'll see that
all of one time before you'll never
speak to me again I wouldn't I won't get
to the half of it jump off balconies how
many have you jumped off and survived
bam trust me how are you here I'm I I'm
telling you I will witness it once you
won't see me again I actually don't
think I could witness someone's
Sleepwalk I would have a panic attack oh
it'd be scary if you're like babe what
are you doing
babe
and he said jump off a balcony
James I would have a panic attack
because I'm jumping in the evenings as
it is
I can't wake up yeah
and you know where your eyes are so sore
yeah open them bro
yeah and you're just there like this is
what I'm saying I'm still defrosting
yeah
I'm still defrosted
let me cook what's up either I'm trying
to act [__] sake
[Laughter]
let's see there's like yeah
babe
and just she jumps off a balcony dolphin
Dives fam dolphin dies I'll scream hey
she'll wake up me there I'm running over
to look over and she's back in the
middle of Smashing TVs
there's no way no I'm packing my duffel
bag then
that is hilarious oh my God cool uh last
one yeah
I have bad genetics I'll probably die
young and our kids are bound to be
unhealthy
bound to be unhealthy
wow that's stressful that's really
stressful you have to tell your partner
that yeah I have to tell your partner my
mom and my dad
large
what do you mean no I'm saying she's got
bad genetics
when you said your Mommy
what's going on yeah what's your parents
got they ain't told me if I'm not
speaking what's going on
are we about to say some confession
yeah she's letting her know yeah that's
that's Peak all right but yeah welcome
to the show guys welcome to the show
guys happy Monday I hope you're feeling
juicy
um yeah man I'm feeling fantastic today
um if you really care about us the way
you say you do please head on over to
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
and please contribute a wholesome three
pound a month send me a day run the p
real quick to SMG and we're gonna get
you a bonus episode every single
Thursday you've got three years of uh
backlog content to catch up on binge
away on there and please enter our
fantastic flourishing Discord Channel
and meet and greet all the other cult
babies in the sng community
uh guys if you're watching on YouTube
please subscribe to the channel it means
everything to us please sing in the
comments haven't said that one in ages
do you have it show up some things in
the comments guys uh the comments are
getting dry chirp some some things in
there make some bonds make some
relationships you already know how it is
and if you are watching on listening on
even any of the podcast apps whatever
platform you're on please give us a
follow subscribe to the channel leave us
a nice five-star preferable review
um and yeah help us grow we want to grow
we want more bags bro we do full
transparency we want and we need more
bags any more burkans in his beard we
want more bags we want to be wealthier
and greedier and more selfish
um and this is the way we do it and uh
if you guys aren't on board with that
then
bye bye fam bye family bye bye if you
don't want to live vicariously through
our ridiculous spending
and grotesque Behavior then see you
later bye we're not on it
um but before we carry on I've got a
real quick question I don't know why it
pops into my head uh it's probably what
we were speaking uh to Ethan about the
other day how much based on your current
like stature
how much to get um a BBL
why would I want to get people you
wouldn't that's why I said how much it's
not paying you not how much you can
spend
um how much how much
how much would I need to pay you to get
a PDF
BBL how big are we talking like I'm
talking about a shelf like that what
like my brother there's a white guy
that's on like Tick Tock or um Twitter
he just walks right with security yeah
he's got a fat back
[Music]
a juicy istan bullion oh that's BBL now
that's gonna be such an inconvenience
tomorrow oh fam
such an inconvenience
I don't bro I don't know I don't think I
can take the money I'm not gonna lie to
you really I feel like I'll attract
people that I don't want in my life yeah
do you know what I mean I will attract a
level of a level of playing field I've
never seen before you're making friends
that you didn't realize were so friendly
[Music]
I don't really think I can facilitate
that dream for them for these men yeah
like darkest man is just messaging you
more and more and you don't understand
why
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'll become some resident Studio bad B
and I just don't really know how that
sits more with me I can't bro
[Music]
I can't bro
wow a BBL a BBL bro no bro don't pay me
yeah I promise you don't pay me don't
pay me all right second question how
much
to have a distractingly big wood
like soft yeah like I'm saying whatever
you wear like you're sat here right now
and it's just there and you can't escape
it bro
it's sexy for like five minutes annoying
for the rest of the 24 hours and things
are just like straight up like harassing
you
nah man I mean I think for a day it'll
be fun yeah yeah like 24 hours I would I
would soak it up but apart from that
how much
um
I would rather that than the BBL and
it's just it's just our orders it's just
there so annoying it's annoyingly there
but it doesn't inconvenience you in the
bed in the bed yeah actually you're
getting a reverse erection oh so we get
smaller and compact so it's like a it's
like a pen size yeah when you're hard
but it just means you can crack on okay
hmm but she doesn't know it got smaller
yeah I was going to say yeah I was
thinking he's having the time
she's unaware yeah yeah yeah
she doesn't understand
yeah
but just visually here every day
um you're in the gym it's just swinging
the shorts you're in the studio it's
hanging down your leg oh my God you just
walk into the shop and there's just
things like oh my god oh that's
impractical like that yeah yeah Snapchat
and stuff I mean if I could do it as
impermanent or could I do it for a day
oh no permanent bro
for the inconvenience I'd have to say
seven figures is that it like a milli
not like maybe eight figures yeah I was
thinking more eight like yeah 10 mil
yeah maybe 15. yeah maybe 50 mil yeah 50
mil to have a fat wood yeah because I
would be annoyed I wouldn't want to
leave my yard oh you're anxiety through
the roof every single ad
throwback to last week's episode of the
week before I'll be wearing them Banana
Boat things them jeans someone said they
were called actually called carrot jeans
yeah yeah they were carrot jeans I
remember
um
I'd be wearing them [__] every day
yeah that's um that's long man it is
long 50 M's 50. I'm excited about you uh
probably similar because I need I need
to not I need some not want to leave my
yard yeah yeah and have everything I
need everything I need is here
everything I need is here and then yeah
what about a bbr
there's definitely a number
do I have a BBL
and they've got to ride the plane
backwards on the way home
yeah and you can't sit down sit down
your eyes have to be out with the air
yeah yeah I'm just laying on my front
for months
for the rest of your life just go into
the just going to get lymphatic drainage
yeah where they have to like rub my yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
waist is doing wow
wow I'm doing up hourglass yeah you're
the fattest guy you can't go shops James
you can't go shots it's long for you in
the summer you can't wear shorts oh you
can't fall bro oh facts because like man
them just see yes so they won't even
know what's on top they won't even see
that like yeah if it weren't these
drones yeah they're they're just here
juicy fat body that's what you're
adulting oh a tall tick with a [__] what
a fade fresh Jays oh yeah body fat on
the neck
[Music]
they're grabbing me
they will understand why my shoulders
are wide yeah
oh it'll scream it was fine they'll
screaming squeeze they'll squeeze and
run
squeeze and run squeeze it yeah
wow we'll squeeze and run
I couldn't be perfect so the man handed
me clock on my breath then just before
they Retreat they're still squeezing my
body and dip
nah bro um
yeah
no it has to be like oh I'd have to be
like a billion yeah to deal with the
male gays
hello this is what this is what's like
to be a woman yeah just to deal with the
male gays I would take a billion pounds
yeah yeah yeah because you wouldn't want
to leave your yard
wow man are having me up literally you
can't go shop bro you can't go Club you
can't go I can't go down anywhere I
can't go dance anywhere Jim is long oh
Jim's game over you have to have a home
team on the treadmill
Daddy's got a baby waste as it is bro
and I got them juicy thighs it's love
for you oh they were nowhere here a bald
[__] tatted up
fat ass yeah it's game over bro billion
run me a billion pounds yeah cause
you're yeah somehow will touch you up oh
certain amounts
especially man that just just come at a
pen
they've never seen a snack like that
they've never seen a bearded Snapchat
so that's a lemon sorbet that's a
palette cleanser Jesus Christ yeah
that's the transition to get back into
gempop
[Music]
they'll probably thinking I was in for
too long because I don't know what's
going on in these streets I was inside
for too long I've never been so confused
bro and you look down is this me or yeah
[Laughter]
it's too funny Oh my days right guys
let's take a very quick break and we're
keeping the lights on today so fellas
have you started spring cleaning yet
the carpets need cleaning the drapes
need dusting and your lawn needs mowing
let's go spring has sprung and the
global leaders in below the waist
grooming have the best tools for
cleaning R5 in your pants you guessed it
time to clear out your winter Bush and
join the four other other four million
men worldwide who trust manscaped by
going to manscape.com for 20 off and
free shipping with the code
sng Sierra November golf come on and
that's going to give you like I said 20
off and free shipping worldwide thank
you very much let's get back to the
shenanigans here we go uh you got
another question or was that no I've
actually got a thread though oh here
before we jump into top five right this
is a dumb little one that someone sent
me you've probably seen it all right so
it goes
so if oxtail is the tail of an ox
that must mean baby powder is
part of a baby powder of a baby that
would mean toothpaste is the paste of
tooth or teeth
the pace of some teeth bro
buffalo wings
Brody's manager made so baby back ribs
is bro
baby back ribs bro
so does baby formula make babies or is
it made of babies
facts wait until you find out whether
yeast in bread comes from someone said
coochie
caps bro all caps cushy question yeast
bro wow a cockroach is oh God bam and
that's the end of it
quick little Ensemble I've never seen
that one before that's jokes bro funny
baby back ribs is
um right guys ready for top five top
five top five top five top five this
week's top five again is a slight
tangent to the main top fives it's an
acronym game we've played this before
with you like a year and a half ago but
we're in it up for for these man an
acronym game acronym quiz yeah oh God so
after every acronym I say I want you to
guys to give me what the acronym is and
then I'll give you a point or no points
if that makes sense so for example if I
ask you what does yolo mean wow
cool cool cool but yeah cool we've got
it yeah I'm ready
all right the first acronym is
GPS
scientific
unless you locked in yeah right I have
no idea
that's right something bro I can't do
that phone because it's gone
bro right
yeah I don't know if I'm I don't know
locked in I'm locked in I'm nervous uh
Ellis what you got okay so I've put
geographical positioning system it's a
wild guess geographical positioning
system yeah cool REM service I don't
know something something service
close I've put Geographic positioning
satellite okay
system sounds better though my original
I originally wrote software okay and
then I put a satellite okay I'm scared
so see what you said what is your
Geographic positioning satellite is that
yours Geographic positioning system
you're both wrong unfortunately it's a
global positioning system so you were
closer okay okay okay say less but I was
close close
all right global global positioning see
your graphic sounds cool yeah you guys
unless I knew every day all right next
one
ADHD
tricky you know well done this is a good
one this is really hard yeah this is
difficult pulse
[Music]
this is really hard pause
you guys are a bad influence
are we all locked in
you haven't got anything
honestly I'm struggling with that one
struggling I'm gonna have to pass on
this all right so you're gonna have to
pass all right Ram tell me what you got
I'm not sure about the H but I've got
attention deficit disorder
well you have to tell me what the H is I
don't know it's not adds it's ADHD well
I'm gonna have to say the L because I
don't know what the H is all right Jimmy
I've got Attention Deficit Hyperactive
Disorder I'll give it to you is
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
so it's yeah same thing it's not like
you were wrong gang even though you were
sometimes
so why did you look fantastic regardless
to put two Rhymes together he stumbles
yeah that's that's got nothing to do
with quizzes quizzing your brain my guy
anyway moving on moving on next acronym
pm and when I say PM I mean like Am Pm
not PM prime minister
I knew you were of course just support
side please don't beat me like that
blood
your face said it all just put something
[Music]
and I feel like you know when you're in
the exam and the teacher walks past your
desk
make sure you read the question properly
oh did you read the question bro Aaron
has four apples she's screaming at you
she's screaming at you take away two
apples how many apples does he have left
and she's looking at your answer you're
looking up at her like Miss is it right
Aaron has four apples
I need to pass I've done year five twice
now right um Ellis what you got it's not
right I know it's not I've got post
morning that's the only thing I can
think of I know it's going to be
something super complicated that's not
bad that's not bad rent same post
morning already yeah you didn't write
postmarks no I actually wrote post Mor
but I think it's a different word but um
yeah it's I'm around there I actually
think these men is better I put past
midday
okay you're all wrong it's post meridian
okay yeah we're already in that
that's damn bro Meridian yeah the mean
man no idea all right two more to go two
more yeah yeah
the next acronym you ready
ESPN
no I don't know just think about it
but you know what kind of shirt is
patronizing Bro think about it it's a
news channel right
[Laughter]
what is it
it is isn't it you're going nowhere bro
wherever you locked yeah you'll pass it
I'm gonna have to pass again
all right Jimmy what you got oh right
I've got exclusive sports program
Network
okay
that sounds better than mine I've got
Entertainment Sports
plays network plays Network yeah
it's pizza because
the way you said it plays Network yeah
it's intimate yeah the sports plays
Network that's what I was going with it
yeah yeah yeah I hear that still good
it's annoying because you are so close
it's actually entertainment and Sports
Programming Network so you were half
half right because he said what did you
say I said exclusive exclusive yeah and
you said Entertainment Sports plays that
work so close all right last one last
one the last acronym of the day is AWOL
I think I know this one a w-o-l all I've
got is for a is away that's it
away blank REM what you got
away without
something leave
I I skipped a
that's all yeah I'm stuck between
the first one I can't remember if it's
away or absent these men are saying away
so I'm just gonna say away away without
authorized leave
or absent without authorized leave is it
a-w-o-l or
a-w-a-l-o-w-o-l it's not yes
oh well
okay my bad all right took it it's
absent without leave
without leave yeah oh the without the wo
is without without
magnificent without leave that's a dub
for me bro that's a point for me
why would you say I said oh wait say
absent yeah
that was the acronym game guys
um total scores are James one Ellis nil
REM nil this one says official leave
just saying this one says absent without
official leave not without leave oh okay
absent without official leave absent
without I've
I've always known as absent without
leave I thought I knew it was I knew it
was four different ones I thought that's
why I would never question you usually
as I had to Google it say less but
either way either way yes
um so I think that's four two zero four
two zero four two zip yeah um but yeah
that was top five top five top five
we're gonna get into some juicy chat oh
Maps up about Married at First Sight
Australia I'm 11 episodes in
it's gonna get juicy right so guys
buckling stay with me so obviously last
week I said
bear in mind I skipped last week so you
say when I said I'd seen episode one and
two I saw a snippet of Jesse getting
told by Claire that she'd lips Adam
right yes yes I told you that yes yes
yes yes bearing in mind I was on episode
two and then I saw that bro I still
haven't made it to that point oh I've
been watching this [__] all week I
still haven't made it back to that
episode they published too many episodes
okay Monday to Thursday is just four
times a week it's just too much big
brother talk bro too much it's a lot
right so oh what I've been watching guys
if you don't mind playing back with me
it's been juicy okay it's been juicy I'm
listening right so
first thing so what has happened though
this is why I know Jesse was crying
because when I said that Jesse when he
found out that she lift Adam he was
crying his eyes out now I know why bro
they gaslit the [__] out of him okay as
a unit they gaslit him so basically what
happened was they all went on the night
out told you that yeah Adam and Claire
went outside and then Jesse was like
sauce then Jesse went home
um and left after Claire mm-hmm
he was home like two hours before she
was
sorry bro he was about two hours of war
and he left after her he left after her
so when she gets home she's got her
phone on a loudspeaker
loudspeaker and he here's a guy laughing
and he says it sounds exactly like Adam
so he said to her who chatted to yeah he
she didn't know he was in a yard bro
who's trying to locks off she said girls
I've gotta go hung up the phone man said
say let's run your phone right now girls
I've gotta go fam run me your phone
right now she said get away from me I
don't know I met you last night showing
you nothing he said say less burst out
the door knocked on Adam's door said run
me your phone today big man Adam said
move you know and his wife's back there
what scan was 2 A.M yeah so he said so
he he was up in the yard just causing a
ruckus said I know something's up I know
so anyway they argue argue argue argue
they get to the commitment ceremony he
sits down in front of the experts and
says look this [__] is a liar like I'm
trying to I'm trying to build Bridges
but she's a liar and Adam's a liar like
something happened I heard him on the
phone and she says pause big man well
who I was actually on the phone with was
my brethren who's a guy who's looking
after my dogs back home so I can be here
with you
and then everyone's like
and then Adams in his yard and his wife
said yeah and I Adam was on the phone
when
um he got home they went to her because
he was on the phone to this guy and this
guy and then the guys are like yeah
Santa see who actually was he what she
was and then Jesse is like oh wow wow
and the experts are like how do you feel
big man he said I actually feel like
[__]
I feel like [__] yeah then one of the
other wives
Lindell yeah Lindell jumps in yeah and
she's like I'm not gonna lie you man I'm
Peyton Jesse out to be a liar
but I heard something
in this night how I heard certain okay
and she said correct me if I'm wrong oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah I heard Adam say
okay please don't leave if you leave you
know I'm going home with Claire
wow fine she said it in front of
everyone Adam said no no no because
before she said that he was beefing just
yeah yeah yeah yeah come into my yard
like a dick oh my God as soon as she
said that she said no no no he said no
no no no no everyone was flirting with
everyone I was just saying stuff
I would never ever he's like why would I
why why would I want to go home with
Claire like my babes is at home and
where me Claire could even gonna go bro
and he said anything he said you know
he's a cheat he said if I was going home
with Claire what difference does it make
if anyone else is going home I'm going
home with Claire my guy so it doesn't
matter if lindel's going home it doesn't
matter Jess is going home if I'm going
home I'm going home with Claire so why
would I say that and they were like hmm
his wife was
say less so that's the juice who's
Adam's wife uh Janelle Janelle so Adam's
wife is Janelle right she's just been
bearing in mind she was the one who said
he's broke as [__] on day one okay she's
been muzzled up until this point
Adam's just been doing it once he's been
running up on Mark and he's apologize to
her yeah and just said stuff's been
coming on yeah and you just been firming
it yeah and I'm sorry but I would never
cheat I'll never lie yeah but you've
been firming yeah and then they had a in
the in one of the weeks
um one of the challenges was to swap
phones
he said you're not touching my phone
and he spot a Web of Lies I think it
says more for our relationship if we
don't go through each other's voice yeah
because anyone can snap up the
opportunity trust me trust me you ain't
gonna go for myself yeah and she was
like um
she said maybe I'll just take a peek
and then she said maybe I'll just take a
pee for like 10 minutes
10 minutes a peek he shut the whole
thing down we're not playing this game
yeah yeah you're not touching my phone
so that's the juice in that and the
dread because she actually comes out now
I know that she comes out and tells him
I did lips him no wonder he cries
because they gaslit him for weeks bro
multiple weeks they Gaslight Jesse wow
so when he finds out his whole world
crumbles down because he thought
something yeah then was sackled by
everyone saying you're possessive and
you're crazy
even the exports everyone's saying
you're insecure you're pathetic you're
aggressive you're everything and he's
like sorry sorry he bought Adam a
present to say sorry and Adams accepted
it smiling his face
I would fight every producer in that
room
but I would fight every producer in that
room and drown bodies in that swimming
pool gave them a gift of champagne and
said I'm so sorry for the drama of
course you're a real one Adam you're a
real one Janelle I'm sorry
Claire I'm sorry he went straight back
because they moved out he went straight
back and said I want to come home
I'm sorry little did you know little did
he know their lips
they lips and gaslit him giggled fam
next next juicy Cup this season yeah
there's
[__] Boys on this season bro hey bro
absolute scum oh my guy Harrison yeah
right Harrison's with Bronte yeah Harris
so Harris is the one who banged her okay
and then the next day I was like I'm
just not feeling you because of the face
thing or nah no no no no no no Janelle's
the makeup artist okay okay okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah Harrison bang Bronte
Saturn happened in to this day I don't
think we still know what happened during
this bang okay he basically was just
like I'm not feeling it post and I was
like post night he was I'm just I can't
I don't find you attractive anymore wow
I tried her eyes out I bet bearing of
mine Harrison's the craziest narcissist
you've ever seen in your life bro this
guy can't apologize
he can't he can't do it he doesn't have
to do it so Harrison's the one who
brontes breger in said he's got a Ting
on the outside yes yes who's got a link
one as soon as it's right yeah yeah he's
coming okay so Harrison's like this is
[__] your girlfriends
so it's come out now it's come out now
who put him under pressure someone
stepped on his neck Melinda okay yeah
this is the thing right so here's the
problem with Harrison and Bronte
Harrison gets away with his narcissism
because Bronte can't control her
emotions bro okay she can't control her
emotions anytime he gaslights her or any
time he's narcissistic she screams and
cries and man says look what you're
doing yeah I'm trying he if I'm he flips
the whole thing he says I'm giving
everything to you and every time we get
into a heat discussion you walk out you
kick me out you say you want space I'm
here yeah I'm trying Melinda won't play
in it bro when they went when it was at
the dinner yeah she was just like you're
a fat boy and any excuse that he would
give to Bronte that won't be a Bronte
cry blender would listen it and be like
[__] like explain yourself she she
says calm bro and Harrison can't
navigate yeah yeah he needs to get you
here yeah he intentionally gets you
heated so that when you're heated you
can walk away he can walk away but I I
don't need to be screamed yeah like
that's his game plan so if he can't get
you heated he's [__] so
fan is all coming out he didn't get his
ducks in a row at all he thought he
could just walk in here lie to everyone
okay and no one's gonna find out so
they did some digging her homeboys
Instagram Harrisons Harrison's okay and
they found a picture of his luggage okay
so anyway so anyway he was he was doing
all sorts and he was basically been like
look I came into this experiment I was a
bit of a football on the outside but I'm
not the same guy as I was as soon as I
walked down that aisle I had my
commitment I'm here like I I don't want
the streets I want to be married
bronzi ate it up yeah at the time yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um that's why she freed it up to him on
night that's why she freed it up on
night one you'd love her because she
hates bras bro she's got fake digs and
she hates I ain't seen her in a bra
[Music]
cake and it was just like a dome with a
charity
anyway yeah um so
he's been gaslighting Gaslight
gaslighting come to The Experts now and
then he's like bro I'm trying she's just
saying she wants space she's doing this
she's doing that I'm trying I'm doing
the most and then she said big man you
were linking a Ting all the way up until
you came in here he's like no I wasn't
no it wasn't and she was like yes you
were like
um what was it it was like you were like
adding her in your Instagram I've seen a
picture of your luggage he said I didn't
see her for a time before I came here
yeah and then she's like unless you were
bro you're taking pictures of your
luggage adding her in it and then he
[__] up and said how did you know she
didn't take that picture everyone's so
idiot
idiot and she said
did she help you pack
and man said
[Music]
said did you tell this thing it's locked
when you're getting here and he said I
shouldn't have to tell her it's not like
she knows I'm coming here to get married
I shouldn't have to tell her it's a big
man you need to tell her she's packing
your luggage yeah and he was like
game is a game bro leave me alone fine I
don't need these questions oh my he's
crazy bro Harrison's crazy bro
next
who we got next oh my God we got some
juicy ones
finish with a bang okay next
in fact I'm gonna finish with a bag all
right cool cool we've got
Shannon and Caitlin Shannon was Caitlyn
fam Shannon
yeah yeah Shannon's a mini Harrison oh
swear so Shannon gets a call one day and
bear in mind everything's blessed with
these two yeah everything's blessed yeah
Caitlyn loves him he loves her so we
thought so bro randomly we're we're
going through everyone's rooms seeing
all the couples are snuggling down in
bed everything's winding down for the
evening bro yeah next thing cameraman's
disheveled we're watching the cameraman
things like this yeah
in the hallway oh oh he's in the field
position on the phone crying oh wow they
go back in the yard Katelyn's kissing
her teeth said he's on the phone to his
ex
he's on the phone to his ex
he comes in and says I can't lie I'm not
a liar I can't lie bearing in mind he
can't because one of the challenges they
love this challenge it's my least
favorite challenge but I love it
secretly yeah they get all the other
contestants and you have to rank them by
how pain they are okay and then you have
your Mrs or your husband or you slide
them and you slide them where there's
okay obviously number one every time you
have to put the you have to put your
husband or wife number one obviously
that's basic rules yes basic math yeah
he's not a liar he put a like fan he put
her like fourth he drinks out of out of
ten oh there's 10 girl terms
a man said look
you've got the potential to be here but
you're just not meeting your potential
you could be number two didn't say
number one you could be number two but
he put what's her face Melinda number
one and said that's a baddie he put
Melinda number one and said this is the
[__] you show your friends off to oh my
God this is the kind of yeah you bring
on your friends and they say gang gang
gang
to his wife he's saying this WOW mad bro
is it the potential but Melinda buddy
who's Melinda with oh she's with
Leighton was late in gast
oh my goodness so anyway that she's
already down bad from that yeah then
he's crying on the phone to his ex then
he comes back in and says babes I'm
sorry I think I love her we've been back
and forth back and forth I think I
[__] love her oh my goodness Cadence
like
you actually think I won't go home now
yeah yeah wow you're actually mugging me
off and while he's crying she's rubbing
his back
so anyway get to commitment ceremony now
what the [__]
and then said oh we've got they sit down
and said how's your week been I said
we've got a bit of an issue so what is
it this is Shannon this is Shannon I
think I'm in love with my ex they
weren't having a piece of it they said
what do you mean you think big man do
you love her or not Caitlyn said he does
he was he big man was in tears the other
day bam he was in the hallway in a fetal
position crying his eyes out yeah and
they said it's heartbreaking they said
while going for this ex like when's the
last time you saw her a week before I
got here oh my goodness did you bang her
yes oh my goodness fam so the brat
expert at this point had enough yeah and
he said you and you yeah yeah you and
you if you man were honest and you're
way in here I swear down you wouldn't be
sat here yeah I swear down you wouldn't
be saying [__] you [__] you what is this
yeah man looks right now what is going
on this season [__] boy Central yeah
Adam's lips and [__] Shadows banging
his ex this guy's got a next thing
packing his God
he said this week fix the [__] up or
everyone's going home he had enough yeah
I said religious I've seen some [__]
yeah on this sofa but raw you man you're
on stuff okay juicy bro okay let me
finish
the last couple of touch on on this week
yeah yeah yeah brother
Josh and Melissa don't don't there are
middle-aged sweethearts Josh and Melissa
Josh is middle age still yeah yeah
heartbreaking
hot this bread seemed more to me as well
so there could be stuff I'm not even
talking yeah I'm waiting to be fair but
now yeah I know you're talking about but
I'm listening Melissa wants [__] and
that's it Melissa wants [__] and that's
it my guy no fam it's not oh it's not oh
they're married it's not sexy bro yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no I'm
just hearing stuff
I promise you on day one you'll be
gassed yeah yeah after a while
she doesn't need your face big man she
makes it clear she don't care what you
look like just bang me oh fam listen to
this so from the day of their wedding
yeah she was like he's buff like
um I was I told the experts I'm looking
for Thor and big man I hope he has
Thor's hammer and bear in mind so what
they did yeah
and they banged on the first night yeah
and she came out the next day was
running her mouth like yeah we bang we
banged it was banging they interviewed
Josh and said oh did you bang last night
he was at now above we didn't buy
someone's lying turns out it was
actually him I thought she was lying
because she was doing the most
um but yeah it turns out it was him and
she was like why are you lying like why
are you ashamed of me I'm not ashamed of
you I'm just a gentleman I don't need to
be telling people I'm banging you like
why do we need to tell anyone that fam
every sentence of every day bro is
basically why aren't you banging me more
and he's like yo like and she's like I'm
she's like I think you're scared of a
powerful woman I think like you don't
know how to love big man like I'm here
you're not lips in me you're not banging
me and he's like bro we've been banging
like
she's like I was in a sexless marriage
I'm not doing it again I promise you
I'll leave today she's so intense for
you and she's literally a bang me bang
me bang bang me and he's like yo he said
bro I'm not a sex object love me I came
here for love yeah and she was like
this is how I express my love like and
he's like you can't think about anything
but sex she was like big man that's not
true he goes what do I do for work big
one they've been together for two weeks
at this point he said what's my job she
was like I don't [__] know
but if I'm her brain shifted for that
she said wow wow she said okay okay okay
he's that's he's suicide she says I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry let's not buy
I don't [__] she said I don't know yeah
yeah yeah he said let's not bang for a
bit yeah let's get to know each other
fan he was like calm
she can't speak yeah when they're sat
there and the sex is not involved she
just Zips the [__] up and she was
cussing him because she said on day one
he said what kind of bread do you like
she said I'm a Sourdough sourdough girl
this is day one bro okay
two weeks into the Ting
um he said he likes English muffins in
it okay so he went above and beyond and
said I managed to find sourdough English
muffins so we can meet in the middle
yeah kind of thing
everyone was like oh that's sweet he
listens fam she went backstage and was
like this [__] talk about toast
like talking about I don't know him he's
supposed to he wants to connect oh we
spoke about his toast
this guy's useless fancy beefs him every
chance she gets she's like bang me bang
me bang me bangy you're a [__] hole
you're not a man bang me bang me bang me
why are you not banging me bro you're a
waste man you think I want a roommate
bang me shut up bang me what bro
[Music]
she's like you don't have to love my guy
what's going on with you like you're a
shell of a man bro what are you doing ah
stop all that Sam you can't take it stop
all of it and he's not confrontational
like that now so he sits there like bro
but then when he sits down with the
producer he just bars bro but he never
runs bars to her it's so jarring and
it's annoying as well because the
experts don't see all this footage yeah
they only see the dinner party yeah
that's all they see they don't see so
when they sit down on the sofa she needs
to be cussed bro which they're not
seeing enough so he says his piece she
says her piece and then the Lang Latina
is like nice you should be banging to be
fair it's a big part
he's not understanding bro this [__] is
crazy mad and he's like you don't care
about me all you want is tall oh you
want his pipe it doesn't matter who's on
the end of it yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
I was in a sexless marriage I'm not
doing it again I'm not looking for a
roommate
Daniel get out and then when he's like
calmed down with the banging yeah she
jumps straight to you can't handle me
and you can't keep up if you can't keep
up tell me now go God
and he's like bro let's go in I can't
say the right thing today he can't Josh
can't say [__] bro no that thing ain't
lasting I'll be surprised if it lasts oh
so you ain't seen the commitment
ceremony after that then no sir Jesus
Christ oh dear yeah sounds like one of
them I'll wait for you to take out next
week and I still haven't seen this
LinkedIn this this new addition Evelyn
yeah oh fam you got some catching of
today I'm telling you I've been binging
it bro but it's an hour long and I have
to watch on Channel 4 which has adverts
bro listen listen when you catch up to
the commitment ceremony of Josh
um and Melissa
family yeah
heartbreak I swear hot break all right
you might as well tell me now you might
as well tell me now that she sits on the
sofa basically both of them said in the
silver yeah Josh is in pieces she's dead
just sat there she says and he makes a
point he she says but in front of
everyone I need a man's man oh my God
Rolls Royce he makes a point rolls
reversed these things these things that
she says to him and questioning his
masculinity yeah yeah
you can't do that a man couldn't sit
there on a on a TV show and say I need a
woman's woman oh thanks you couldn't do
that and she's just she's cussing him
out and and she she makes a digger at
how how he lacks intimacy
but to her intimacy is only sex intimacy
can be eaten a whole bunch she don't
know what it is she only knows one
version of it and she's fam Josh breaks
down Mama stands up walks off um dip
after oh yeah family
really
you need to see that it's deep I can't
see stuff like that because if I'm if
that's my boy if you're on the sofa
don't know what to do I swear my wife
has to pin me down
[__] my wife would also pick me down
yeah because I said don't speak to him
like that
yeah oh my I can't imagine a woman
making me cry and leave the building
leave the building so all my boys have
to chase me yeah they're dragged I have
to drag him back drag him back to bring
it back I'm leaving the show I'm leaving
the show and I'm leaving the country I'm
listening when I see some of this stuff
yeah I don't know how the cameraman keep
their jobs factual because when she's
one-to-one Cassie in your mouth I'll
have to drop my camera but listen here
you [__] [__] the microphone
listen here you [__] maybe you're just
buzz how about that facts maybe you're
just bus yeah you've got childhood
trauma that's what you've got yeah bro
don't be putting your sexist marriage on
me oh my God who do you think you are
about you're not a man you've got
intimacy issues he loves her as well he
loves to love oh Josh he's a real one
bro he keeps it all the time yeah when
he has the one-to-one with the cameraman
yeah he loses his [__] yeah and he's
like I can't [__] take this anymore
he's one of them he holds it all in
God you can't hold it anymore I'm not
gonna be able to watch that but I'm not
going to protect them telling you when
you come when you see it you won't
believe it if I'm well don't you oh
she's just she doesn't understand that
he's just so much more conservative you
know what she said as well do you know
do you know I know she's a little [__]
what do you know what she said my
friends were right about you oh my God I
don't remember that yeah bro she's I
should have listened to all my girls bro
her bears that aren't on the show her
girls who were at her wedding who saw
him one time and only one of them was
against him only one of them was like I
don't think he's the type of guy you're
looking for and she even said I don't
think he's about to keep up with you
like you're very hyper you're very
you're a lot I don't think he seems very
like introverted recluse complete
opposite complete I don't think he's for
you one girl said that everyone else
including her twin sister was like he's
gang he seems lovely fam she jumped
straight to my bedrooms were right about
you I should have listened to them at
this table thing in this dinner table no
this is one to one bro trash
is that how it works in real life
but I don't know
I was divorcing bro the commitment
ceremony they choose uh whether to Stay
or Leave okay both of them have to say
stay they stay if one says stay and one
says leave yeah they both they're
contractually obligated to stay for one
more week for one more week to see how
if you come back next week and still say
leave then you leave but there has been
cases of one saying stay one saying
leave yeah and it's the sich is so Peak
toxic bro
yeah I promise you [__] your contract
yeah the professionals are like Nat they
leave one you decide whether you stay or
leave because this your your marriage
here what I'm looking at yeah it's Peak
okay so you decide the lever decides
yeah all right and you'll you'll see in
time from who that who I'm talking about
that happens that's what I'm saying yeah
it happened a couple of times last year
as well bro okay I remember there's one
Brazilian Body who was a cheat last year
she was a chief she was laying she took
one of the other husbands Jesus she took
one of the other husbands who'd been
booted off the show
I definitely spoke about it
banging yeah she was banging and then
her husband was not for her like really
he's Rich she said she loves money so
they pay they paid her up one rich done
but he's lovely not paying okay there
was one massive Wham guy yeah who him
and his wife didn't partner up she
bailed him straight
they were lips in in a bar oh off camera
they tried to get off Cam and it's like
the cameraman could just see half of
what was going on behind like an
Alleyway yeah lips and then he rocked up
to the commitmentary together yeah yeah
and the experts were like who are you
what's going on yeah yeah this is this
is this is sacrilege yeah yeah get out
of here this is Haram get off my couch
yeah yeah yeah but if you should be
ashamed of yourself they said we're in
love shut up
we're in love counsel us yeah we're on
this show like everyone else we're alive
contractually yeah fam it was mad but um
you know this season's getting juicy all
right looking forward to next week's
update yeah I'm not gonna be able to
stumble watching Jessie cry though
because now I've seen the build up yeah
I was thinking why is he crying so much
now I've seen the build up the way they
treated him
the way they treated him if you had
his Show's [__] up that's so juicy
also everyone gets DMV Love is Blind I'm
not watching like I can only stomach so
much traffic yeah yeah yeah you have to
let me watch what I want to watch
the amount of people yeah like how dare
you not speak about this yeah how dare
you not want to let me watch what I want
to watch I've seen a couple episodes of
Love is Blind it's just okay they DM me
the other day did I tell you they did
yeah I think you did yeah to come on
this thing yeah man it's just okay yeah
um but there's a couple of [__] on
there though yeah a couple bits this
season a couple [__] on there yeah I
just remembered yeah as a meanies yeah
oh they're just laughing at everyone's
couples laughing at everyone's couples
and when when one of them is like
breaking down saying oh my man doesn't
obviously you know the premise of the
show in it yeah same a man doesn't want
me
the ones that are laughing at them are
gonna they're trying to console her but
so there's two let's say we are the
meanies right let's see what the meaning
is and I'm trying to console REM yeah
rem's things dumped him rem's saying oh
I don't want ramble about rem's crying
on the sofa I've gone to console REM
knowing where our souls right I've gone
to console Ram like part on the shoulder
kind of thing but I'm looking at you
like I'm looking at you like it's big
the game's the game and then I'm writing
off and snickering with you that's what
these guys are doing wow a couple mean
girls that's what they're doing I
secretly yeah that's what they're doing
what we would do
[__]
[Music]
it's jokes these jokes
yeah this might have a site too I
couldn't be on there bro because I'd be
throwing hands up when I bro if I was
Jesse one I found out that you actually
lips because when he when home girl was
like I could have heard the wrong thing
yeah but I'm pretty sure Adam said this
Jesse said
wow and then Adam was like I could have
said something similar he said big man I
know for a fact you said that but he
still apologized to everyone
Jesse did Jesse did still gave him
presents this was post this it was post
horse light
oh but it wasn't post this yet saying I
heard you say this yeah after he gave
adam a present after
saying I heard you say this because
because the girl first of all the girl
who said it wasn't given like adamancy
she wasn't like she wasn't yeah I know
what you said bro and I know what you
meant yeah she's saying I could have
heard wrong but it sounded like you said
this and all I had to say was like why
would I say that yeah like shut up and
Claire was like
sharp so Jesse was like bro
fam he was crying I forgot to say in his
commitments everything he wrote leave
because he said this experiment brought
the worst out of me oh wow
wow hit me and resonate with me yeah not
liking my current life but in certain
relations I've been in where you're just
like I love you you bring the worst out
of me toxic
you're toxic and you keep bringing me in
bring him in and hurting me and hurting
me and when I react I'm the villain
folks you men are bringing the worst out
of me I haven't slept in days yeah I've
been there boy I'm worried sick yeah
yeah bro when he said that I was like
Wow been there say less I know you've
been there as well been there bro I need
to leave and I said I love her but I
can't stand this anymore I can't help
myself in the mirror selfish she's
cheated on Jessie and decided yourself
that he needs to stay because you as
clear
wants to make things better yeah you you
your decide she's deciding that she's
going to be yeah she's deciding for
Jesse that she's she can make up for it
she can bring it back around so yeah
we're gonna stay
she's paying she's a sweetheart
to be fair she'd get everyone to stay
yeah I don't
she is
[Laughter]
like Jesse's a lovely guy yeah Adam's
like handsome yeah and Charming but like
he's a bit of a bell end okay and Jesse
is not like traditionally paying okay
so I can see why Claire would be
a bit promiscuous but and they've not
banged it at this point I don't think he
banged Claire and Jesse found they
haven't lipsticks
this adamant this cheating firm happened
before before Jesse and Claire had done
anything yeah
everyone else had banged
pretty much everyone has Claire was
Johnson Jesse just wasn't down he was
down but he's just he's very he's taking
his time
okay they had arguments as well they've
got lips
I'm lipsing on the first night straight
away oh come on bro straight away yeah
um but yeah that's what's cooking at the
minute okay it's so juicy okay I'm going
straight home after this okay but I'm
gonna have to watch it on something else
yeah because of the website because this
channel for adverting they're taking a
piss out I mean yeah I can't stand it
for and they they finesse you as well
because if I'm watching on my laptop and
you've got the tab once the advert's
running you're not allowed to switch
tabs you can't you can't skip you can't
change tabs oh so if I if I'm watching
channel 4 on this tab and the adverts
come in I can't go over to YouTube and
wait for the adverse to end no as soon
as you change tabs they know you've
changed tabs and it pauses the thing
that's crazy not sprawled yeah I tried
to watch I try to watch last uh whatever
I'll try to watch Tuesday's up to catch
up before we spoke about it today
and on the app my LG TV app Channel 4
app and it says in the corner four
minutes of adverts
an accident I came off it accidentally
went to go back to it it started
cool you've got a thread for us now so
um I found this thread on BuzzFeed I've
had it on my phone for ages I just
completely forgot about it so the
caption is
I didn't even care to argue people share
when they realize their wedding was a
mistake
oh
very on Trend facts
I knew when he inherited a house and
gave it to his son in Brackets my
stepson without even mentioning it to me
I overheard it when he was on the phone
with his ex-wife
that's interesting
that's very
very interesting in terms of just like
so she thought she's saying
because he left it to his son and didn't
discuss it with her
marriage was a mistake that's grounds
for divorce
I mean
I can see it from both sides
keep your hands on my pockets
yeah
keep your hand on my [__] yeah I'm
inheriting something I'm giving it
straight to my son
What's It Gonna Do With You
what what's it actually got to do with
you but also I can also see the raw side
of it yeah your belly my wife did that
to me
I'll be like wow yeah interesting yeah
obviously your boy makes bags I don't
need your yard but interesting very
interesting yeah I realized when I
didn't I realized when I didn't even
care to argue about the things that
bothered me he thought that was a he
thought the lack of arguments was a
positive sign I just saw it as a sign of
giving up
that's horrible that is horrible
hmm I wondered if I've ever felt like
that we'll just sign up just giving up
yeah just a sign of like if I can't be
bothered to argue it's like a negative
on the relationship
um I can't remember to argue period fact
that's what I'm saying I'm not a big
argument sometimes I am though yeah
I am if you push me though yeah yeah
yeah that's true
but I like peace of mind
so
I don't know I don't think I've been in
the situation where I was like you know
what because I think it's one of those
ones where
I will probably hear something or
something be said to me that will
trigger me to make me like I have to I
have to Stand My Ground yeah you're
wrong what you're saying is wrong
I'm here I'm there now what you're
saying is wrong
I get so angry what you're saying is so
incorrect I didn't say that I didn't say
that yeah facts I've been there
wrong
I did not say that
that's hilarious Oh my days
all right next one
I had a panic attack at the thought of
being trapped with him forever I think
we both knew it wasn't right but felt
obliged to continue
he now has the family he wanted I'm free
Jesus Christ bro what is this oh
when he complained about the cost of gas
to drive our four-year-old daughter to
speech therapy
yeah she said my marriage a mistake yeah
she needs speech therapy a man said the
gas prices are mad they're Bonkers how
badly does she need to speak yeah facts
how bad does she needs yeah she'll grow
out of it
grow out of it you know wow my now
ex-husband didn't dance with me at our
wedding so that was a good indication
didn't dance with me at the wedding I
mean
it would be to be fair
it would be discussed prior
but there is like a 50 50 chance I won't
be dancing with anyone in my wedding
why because I'm not standing up in front
of 200 people in an empty dance floor
doing this I'm just not doing it I just
don't have to make a spectacle of myself
oh okay okay okay okay I thought you're
talking about first stance oh yeah I'm
just talking I thought about your
wedding in general
yeah we're gonna be doing stuff all
night yeah yeah yeah we're gonna be
doing stuff all day and all night I'm
gonna be drunk and handset
I need to make sure and I need to make
sure all my boys are getting it in
do I mean don't render me breakfast but
dang yeah out of all my single brethrens
I need an equal numbers
that come in as well everybody's getting
intimate
so yeah I'm grips in my wife
but in terms of first dance don't be
surprised if that does not happen at my
wedding okay I don't like stuff like
that say less it makes me just feel
awkward fair enough fair enough I
couldn't care less yeah first I really
couldn't care less yes or no
um as I drove up our street after work
and I saw his truck there already my
heart sank it was like going from light
to dark I moved out four months later
I'm confused she just hated the fact
that he was home Oh
I thought she was saying like oh he's
lying about working I was like nah she
just hated the fact that he was home
wow fam that's actually dread that's how
I used to feel growing up when like I
remember like
um there was time in my life like yeah
just didn't get on with my mom okay and
like if I ever came home from school and
my mom's car was there yeah
or if I just woke up in the morning and
my mom's not getting ready for work yeah
she's just in a dressing gown and I'm
like what's going on yeah he was like
I'm off today
yeah okay [__] yeah come on man
yeah I don't want to talk I don't want
to deal with this I know some beef is
gonna ensue so that for your your life
partner wow wow the person you chose to
be with that's how you feel rolled your
eyes when I saw the car bro that's drag
all right uh last one
honestly I realized three months after
we got married then I stuck out for
another 12 years and put myself through
three kids
um and put my three kids through hell
sorry I wish I'd been strong enough to
leave in the beginning
what was the point
what's the point this is one of the
darkest threads we've ever read what's
what is that literally what is the point
what's the point of that
you thought you could stick out this
whole stick out stuff I can't stand I
can't stand stuff like that that was the
same sorry to bring it back on uh Bronte
and Harrison's commitment yes she wrote
stay because she said Mama didn't raise
a quitter he hates you
like and you hate him yeah and she's
saying Mama didn't raise it quit I was
just dick you out and I just done this
whole dance I don't like you raps bro
you don't like him what's the piece of
metal Gonna Change
dumb bro
socially
so I'm very very intrigued for next
week's um yeah I'm super intrigued um
but anyway I think we should wrap it
there man let's do it um guys thank you
very very much this is a buff episode
I've really really enjoyed myself and uh
as always head on over to patreon catch
us there on Thursday for some extra
laughs and um yeah
[Music]
foreign